[Music]
it's not a red carpet but a rainbow one
to welcome gays and lesbians in Uganda
in a few days they plan to hold a parade
here to celebrate diversity in Africa
the carpet isn't quite long enough so
red fabric is added such details are the
least of the activists worries what
they're doing could land them in prison
under Uganda's anti-gay laws which are
among the toughest in the world many are
unwilling to appear on camera one man
says he thinks the police will stop them
if they find out what they're doing
people talk to the media he says or post
something on Facebook
I've arranged to meet some politicians
in the Ugandan capital Kampala I promise
to mention nothing about the planned gay
pride march same-sex relationships are
illegal in Uganda punishable with up to
14 years in prison Parliament has even
discussed the possibility of introducing
tougher sentences some are calling for
the death penalty
like lawmaker Christine Abia one of the
major hardliners even animals generated
that far how come people with conscience
then physiologically disoriented
themselves and then they call it we are
a certain sexual orientation now you
have just disoriented yourself and then
you pretend that it's a human right no
for goodness sake it's a human wrong I'm
shocked by her stance Cristina BIA is
actually known among many Western
organizations as an energetic defender
of women's rights but to me she seems
more like a woman from the Middle Ages I
mean they then beaten by good fish
Richard is one of those that Christina
BIA would like to turn into fish food
the young Ugandan is helping with
preparations for the gay pride march he
came out two years ago and is happy to
appear on camera
[Music]
the next day he even invites me to his
home he's had to move house several
times since coming out because he kept
receiving threats now he's trying to
build up a new life in an apartment on
the edge of the city it's been a very
big change that happened and sometimes
feeling what happened I'm not any
different but why would people start to
like treat me in different or start to
think I'm indifferent just because they
know okay so that's really like really
hot right now he has a friend visiting
from France so he's making coffee which
is unusual in Uganda all right a typical
Ugandan Richard prefers to drink tea
people just have their habits and so
sometimes it's very difficult to change
them and the whole thing drives even to
sexuality
and acceptance in Uganda like matters of
like sexuality its smallest like the
topic sex is discussed in closed doors
that's where the distinction comes with
the West well you can go and demonstrate
on the streets it's very difficult
sometimes to do it here well his friend
Marco drinks his coffee Richard uses the
time to continue preparations for the
gay pride march it's set to culminate
with a parade on Entebbe Beach around 40
kilometers from Kampala Richard is
constantly on his smartphone organizing
I find it amazing that Richard can be so
relaxed given the circumstances he's
even happy you brought the rain
a little while ago he wouldn't have
dared draw attention to himself let
alone go on camera two years ago a
well-known pro gay activist was murdered
in Kampala earlier this year Richard had
to go underground himself a newspaper
published an article on him inciting
hatred amongst its readers they started
way I stay way I studied where I work so
it was more threatening cause with your
address being out there you never know
what would happen to you so it was
really scary so at some point I had I
had to move the tabloid newspapers
regularly turn out anti-gay propaganda
publishing the private addresses of gays
and lesbians I've arranged to meet a
radio presenter named Charles a donk toe
he's one of the few journalists who've
interviewed a homosexual on his show a
step that caused him a lot of problems
but it turns out he's not actually a
defender of homosexual rights he
believes there's another motive behind
the gay and lesbian movement I have seen
two or three people who I have stayed
with as colleagues okay and I knew that
they had no problem at all and then when
they left this country I started hearing
stories that I have been hounded out of
this country I think some of us some
Ugandan use this in order to get a visa
to run out of this country maybe they
think that going to Europe or to the US
or to any other country out of this
place
is it better provides a better
opportunity later I meet up with Richard
again at an Indian restaurant and I tell
him about my conversation he tells me
he's fed up with hearing that
homosexuals are only looking for
financial benefits or asylum abroad he
says that despite all his problems
he's never considered leaving his
homeland
this whole concept of saying that we are
only looking for money to me I would say
it's it's a form of an excuse because
even when you look at the churches like
the evangelicals a lot of money is
coming from the West actually and this
is money that they access that we don't
even have access to and many of those
churches are actively preaching against
homosexuality I've arranged to meet with
a pastor who often talks to the media
about what he sees as the dangers of
homosexuality I meet pastor Solomon
Malik in a suburb of Kampala he's come
to comfort the grandparents of a boy who
was sexually abused three days ago he
says it's the victims of sexual violence
that he's concerned about whether
they're gay or straight then he says he
wants to show me some of the videos he's
filmed which he uses to speak on
homosexuality in schools but the things
he teaches are clearly full of cliches
and prejudices still a pastor male is
not someone who incites hatred against
homosexuals nor does he support
draconian punishments for lesbians and
gays
no one is born gay no one is born in
homosexual if you learn a practice which
hacks your life and we are warned that
look these are the consequences and you
still stay focused on indulging in it
then it's a problem it's now the eve of
the gay pride march the organizers and
participants are holding a small party
at a hotel
most of them come in traditional dress
they posed for photographs on the
rainbow carpet there are more than 50
languages and ethnic cultures in Uganda
Richard is wearing a robe from his home
in eastern Uganda we thought it wise
that as you can dance in nature you
appreciate our cultures and different
traditions and that's why today everyone
is dressed and looking like where they
come from and we are hoping this brings
us more closer to our families who our
own traditions and cultures this evening
everything is happening in secret
the hotel owner supports the gay and
lesbian movement so the atmosphere is
relaxed but how will it be tomorrow when
they take to the streets to demand their
rights
[Music]
the group is meeting at the National
Theatre from here they'll go by bus to
Entebbe the mood is a very different one
today from last night
the police have now got wind of their
plans and the group is very nervous but
the bus arrives and everything continues
as planned
only those with an armband are allowed
to board for security reasons but
there's still no sign of Richard and I'm
starting to feel worried the man sitting
next to me is also looking increasingly
tense he's already been to prison
because of his homosexuality so this
guy's wanted to see how I do it with my
fellow man they can't just get in my
clothes when we get to interpret we
first have to wait for the other buses
to arrive but the group has no problem
passing the time
then suddenly Richard turns up a heart
they recognized him at first because of
his wig he tells me he was stopped by
the local police chief who warned him
that the activists would all be arrested
unless they steer clear of any busy
streets I asked him if he had to pay a
bribe
no comment he says the mood is now more
upbeat
I don't mind is so free today
everybody's being themselves and waving
their flags then comes the big moment in
my heart is almost in my mouth the
Ugandan gay pride march gets underway
[Music]
they've waited for a long time for this
last year the police put a stop to the
parade before it really got started
this time the gays and lesbians are able
to march for half an hour along Entebbe
Beach undisturbed they're very relieved
and begin to dream of a different you
get
[Music]
to have a free and liberated people LGBT
people who live in harmony with the rest
of the community
I've spent nearly a week with Richard
and the others and been impressed by
their courage I've seen problems but
also signs of hope and who knows maybe
next year they'll be able to take their
march from the beach to the center of
Kampala
[Music]